if you're like me you try not to play
Angry Birds too much because the iPhone
game is frankly totally addictive and
rapidly turns you into a social recluse
who does nothing but spend hours staring
at his iPhone well Mattel has an answer
for you starting in May they're going to
have a $15.00 game where you can play
Angry Birds in real life and you can do
this with two or three other players
making it a social experience so here's
how it works there's a deck of 56 cards
you pick a card and it shows you what
kind of structure to build and then your
partner gets these little Angry Bird
guys and puts them in the catapult here
and then flings them at the structure
you get a certain number of points if
you destroy the entire structure and
then you get bonus points if you get the
eggs or the star this is the kind of 3d
gaming that I can actually get excited
about I'm looking forward to when this
comes out too because then maybe I'll be
able to get my iPhone back from my kids